[Music]
in no friend news what mobile is
submitted by the queen of Jamali
oh just a minute us huh Oh chica oh come
on I figured a man ends up in jail after
paying 200 strangers to act as guests at
his wedding
what how do you go to jail salon or is
that I need a prostitution it's a sex
wedding we gotta wait why why so many
people though if you don't have friends
but you don't need 200 there it makes
you feel good in front of her salary may
be just like 30 anyone can go out with a
bang that's what we do with you guys
yeah like a small intimate wedding you
hate everyone yeah yeah wasn't enough so
he didn't go to jail because of hiring
the guests she went to jail after he
hired these guests because it led to
sexy time but first I'll tell you what
happened at the wedding
whoo let's hear the cheese mess so the
groom known only by his surname wing
holotype and his fiancee Shelly so what
is office here people I wish I knew I
wish I could tell you I'm trying to
figure that you Juliette anything I'm
just gonna keep listening oh I forget to
your Chinese right what's the fun one
with the people god damn oh Jesus man
you almost [ __ ] crack your own eating
straw what a [ __ ] are you eating turtle
the bald eagle so much oh my gosh well
we turn over an accident and a bald
eagle - sharks a [ __ ] god damn it
they're endangered River food here
she's got an episode of River Monsters
with a [ __ ] cent of nitrogen all
right so dream the wedding the 27 year
old fried so I was really odd that there
was like a whole section of their way
that was just a whole bunch of empty
tbsp facility at her groom like where is
everyone
he was just like all they're coming
they're on their way don't worry about
it everyone is a
in time that fishy yeah exactly but we
got married on receiveth a clerk so me
wake up you know what's even more fishy
that she's only questioning it now what
are they getting married she never met
any one of his friends didn't meet his
parents or anything like that
once you discover that he was lying she
realized like all the people actually
met they might have been just hired
actors as well once you realize that she
was lying that's what she called the
police I don't know why Chicago East I
was winning married at this point I
don't know if they actually went through
the ceremony part but I do know it was
just during the whole wedding day so
then there were people that kept saying
that they were friends of his and then
people were like well how do you know
him and they couldn't answer that
questions is don't even know him so it
turned out that these people there were
students taxi drivers or people that he
had hit up on weibo and offered to pay
81 or $12 to attend his wedding and then
to pretend that they were like his
family and friends let me show you guys
a picture there improv must be really
good yeah like hey this is my cousin and
I knew him ever since we were 5 years
old and we love to go uh selling and
what was the ocean that specific energy
loved us before God it was a starfish
you were really good at bullshitting
that was good he would not have worked
well did this how'd you like starfish
okay let's do it again I was put on the
spot that's the whole point
all of them there's 200 people coming in
promise pot but he said that they
couldn't answer the question how do you
I'm a friend of his how do you know
Oh is the water over there every time
like they were asked how do you know how
you didn't what I'm so hard to [ __ ]
why you question me can you walk away
this is his empty side oh my God why
would he get so many [ __ ] tables so
he was fronting that he had money
because the bride has money her family
has money killer no no no killing but he
was just trying to get Lincoln he was
getting money from his in-laws and
that's the reason why you went to jail
because fraud because of fraud exactly
dance with a bride Conte for the wedding
I'm assuming that's not they could
afford all those chairs in that giant oh
so he's accused of swindling over 1.1
million John which totals to about a
hundred and sixty thousand dollars from
the family of the bride apparently it
was over a course of a couple years I'm
a little bit I'm kind of like
questioning the girl's motives to then
so the only with everything else okay -
the money fact mmm yeah I mean here
because I think like let's I mean I'd be
pretty pissed that the that the person
lied throughout the whole thing but like
if everything else was cool to the point
where I wanted to marry this person and
the only thing issue that you didn't
have money I think that's something I
could go over well there is one more
issue that I can come oh well actually a
woman no because I also feel like every
Chinese person has gotten arrested for
swindling yeah I don't think that's a
big deal well we probably so the other
reason is when the police arrested him
and they ran a background check on him
it turned out that he was only twenty
years old
Oh two years too young to legally marry
in China for men oh you got to be
twenty-two to marry I need to for a man
and I believe it's 20 for a woman can we
see a picture of this man's face
kind of like that thank you then you
have all these young ask kids marrying
for no reason well he just looks like me
so I don't got a area lemon thank you I
know all these [ __ ] like swingers
look just like Leah shed a little bit
gooks
like for all that racist yes I was
damn yeah but that's not you got a
recipe yeah I'm with David on that
because if it's let's say the age was
fake your friends are fake you have no
money but but the relationship between
you two were [ __ ] awesome I think I
overlooked it's not ours
why because I'd question everything like
if you're this dope person why are you
lying about various [ __ ] like that I can
do it but my biggest question is how
does she not realize he didn't have
money like how is he getting this money
from her family if he supposedly had
money I'll give him maybe he just has
enough like he's not rich or well-off
so everything that he was given was just
to her he kind of lives my spouse maybe
they just had stacks of money in the
house a huge meal of Minnick at what's
crazy we have mutual friends that um
this kind of happened to him
so um he comes from a family with money
and at this point he was living on in
Korea and then he met a girl out there
she claimed that she was the daughter
the daughter of the granddaughter or she
was somehow tied to the Milton get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah that that was like
her family's company so she was ballin
and stuff and this guy's ballin and then
there were just so many like off signs
that mom would see because the mom was
just like so protective of like their
wealth moms like em there something Bob
Skaar don't like jointed the trommel's
like whatever will you know what you
know so now he proposes to her they're
about to get married and then the moms
like wait up so she went behind her
son's back hired a private investigator
and then they found out that all of the
[ __ ] that she was saying was fraudulent
like lie after life's a lie and they
broke up
crazy you know that you get on that now
they're back together
yeah you probably know I didn't know the
doing what I didn't know this some guys
are crazy all right losers nah she had
some amazing vagenis oh it must have
been given profusely I will call exactly
yeah yeah but I think it's kind of sad
because Wang's real parents showed up
after this blew up on the news explosion
no they showed up in the
offered to repay that family everything
that he took from them it's not
interesting there's like one generation
of Chinese has a lot of Honor that's
like that warrior and kung-fu movie you
see and then all of a sudden got the
swing last generation I don't know what
the hell happen but there's life
the fake LD generation and then there's
like the one before that I [ __ ] cut
my head off for you generation it's
interesting because like I always look I
mean we we I mean just on a serious note
video jokes aside when you kind of look
at like Chinese history they are a
curator for taste Mart food everything
if they were the [ __ ] and then somehow
the perception got skew to cheap dad
cheap swindler which I have experienced
myself a little bit here there's no you
look like I'm not denying it but it's
kind of like how did it go from that to
that
so one of the strongest [ __ ]
out there there were a world power of
like a thousand years yeah now they are
two second they're getting room but
they're becoming another world power but
without that same reputation and respect
on it though just look at their pottery
in general it's [ __ ] amazing it's
beautiful
yeah when we went to a Palace of
Versailles in France Napoleon had a room
completely dedicated to just Chinese art
and porcelain and bases and all that
stuff because it was for him it was like
I want France to be like China yeah that
was their viewpoint before and now you
don't use the mean time different how's
it going guys don't forget to like the
video because if you don't I will break
your [ __ ] legs
thank you so much for the last video
don't forget to click right here before
I'll break your [ __ ] arms click right
here you guys
[Music]